so I'm sort of a machine-learning geek
I've been working in the field for about
22 years on machine learning
applications starting with credit card
fraud detection so this is my first job
credit card for detection so you know
used data from banks all over the world
the goal was to detect fraudulent
transactions as they happen we build
machine learning models that Benton the
authorization systems of credit card
processing organizations and when a
transaction came through and neural
network were score it for the
probability of fraud and if possible it
would stop that transaction in real time
so no more losses were incurred so
there's this company called agency
software in San Diego that did this and
at that time credit card fraud had been
climbing through the roof and this was a
huge boon to the banks and made a very
very big difference in their profits but
this is and then you know after about
eight nine years in that company doing a
variety of things
I joined amazon.com as their first VP of
fraud prevention affectionately called
first VP of fraud at Amazon so this is
sort of my job in all of these cases
right in the data transformations that I
had to do most of my time would spend in
taking data from all of these sources
understanding the patterns cleaning the
data munching the data-feature icing the
data building test models evaluating
their performance then changing the
model and iterating all of that so there
was a lot of grunt work and 90% of my
time was cleaning and visualizing the
data and very little on the algorithms
and anything innovative and especially
many other PhD coming out of college you
have a slightly different orientation
unfortunately a mine and this is how I
found
like why did I do a PhD however my this
is what I really did a PhD for 80% of
the time spent preparing the data 20% of
the time it felt like was spent
complaining about the need for preparing
data well you know in a and 99% of
computer users cannot program either
well so the thing is today's 2017
unfortunately we're little has changed
and the vast majority of data scientists
people who work with data spend time
cleaning the data even though you know
this data signs role is sold as the
sexiest job of the 21st century and you
see that you know recognition in all of
these publications as well you know New
York scientists would say in your time
so for big data time the janitor work is
key hurdle to insights so so my dream
even in 1995 was a how could I actually
get rid of all of this heavy lifting at
least could I learn the feature ization
and I couldn't obviously find an
immediate thing for more structured data
on how to avoid the data cleaning
process although these days lots of
progress is being made on applying
machine learning and data wrangling
techniques to automate a bunch of these
but then other dream was hey can we at
least automate the visualization now
that area we are actually finally seeing
some progress with deep neural networks
especially for image text natural
language and that type of data the
traditional structured data in databases
and logs etc we still haven't fully
cracked the nut but for a lot of
unstructured data texts in you know and
natural language and images and speech
and audio on all of those we are
starting to make significant progress
with the energy so you can actually say
look mono feature ization I don't have
to do complex signal processing to
generate features out of these and
that's very very exciting
so what's deep neural network so I'd
write a deep neural networks especially
it's about 10
years now that deep neural networks have
actually caught on in fact it does
anybody here know what really triggered
the big step change in deep neural
networks any updates what it was better
data and computation but also like one
specific data said that was compiled
that actually drove this progress in
deep neural networks and it was not even
a just a simple algorithmic advance it
was just one particular data set anybody
actually the answer is the imagenet data
set compiled by Stanford professor
called phi phi li and imagenet
competition that was created was the
primary driving force to accelerate the
development of B n ends in the last ten
years
now the thing was once a data table
compiled people start applying neural
networks to it and they found that
applying deep neural networks really
have the improve performance over the
state of the odd that was possible
ambition and then that was a major
breakthrough and then it drove a very
accelerated cycle of development so very
few people know that a compilation of
that data set was actually so
instrumental in driving the growth of
the neural networks now anyway so what
deep neural networks are you know they
are really neural networks which have
been around for since the 1980s as a
very popular technique for machine
learning and it's just much deeper and
what happens is very very deep neural
networks are able to learn extremely
sophisticated representations that
shallow ones were not able to do and
they're able to go into the tail of the
data especially when you have a very
large amount of data and like envision
that's really important to understand
the I understand the tail of the data
not just model the macro features of the
data distribution if you look at images
and you look at their macro features you
will see it's a lot of it's a lot of
things about various variation and
brightness variation in the colors
variation and where it's cap
those kinds of macro details are not
good enough to understand the content in
the image itself so to understand the
content the precise content in the image
you have to go into modeling much more
fine-grained statistical features which
deep neural networks are able to do and
that's why deep neural networks have
become very successful and so now
they're used in computer vision language
translation speech recognition and more
and the indents have become the de-facto
cutting edge algorithm to apply for all
unstructured data when you have lots of
data okay if you don't have lots of data
you can't learn the tail obviously
there's not much scheduler okay great
but deep neural networks are also
extremely challenging to deploy in
online services and in real applications
period because some of these are
gigabytes in size because they're really
big with lots of parameters and it's
very hard to deploy them scroll them
it's very hard to learn them first of
all unique GPUs and multiple weeks of
training sometimes are very large data
to learn them and there's a lot of art
around it and lots of people don't
succeed with it unless you are actually
practiced in that art of getting this
deep neural networks to work so that
it's very costly to develop it's very
costly to deploy but if you can do so
you can actually have some really
powerful applications ok so this is just
you know pictures of how these things
look you know you take a very large
image data set in a power it through a
deep neural network you learn the noodle
networks layers learn different
complexities of features in the earlier
layers you will get a basic edge kind of
feature detection in the butts towards
the middle you get more sophisticated
features and at the highest level you
can even get you know things like faces
being recognized and so on
so that's the deep neural networks
ability to learn concepts and multiple
levels of abstraction ok so the question
when you are talking about accelerating
AI development especially for these kind
of things is how can you really scale-up
deep learning
and that is a very important problem at
this point in time it's one of the
cutting edge scenarios and so I mean
have play video here that shows why it's
important to do so so I left the promise
of AI has always been to make lives
better and do things that we're doing
now on our own in a much more efficient
in much more powerful way but to do that
AI need to learn and to learn and needs
information and one of the best sources
of information we have on the world and
how it works is hidden in the video
cameras all around them the phenomenal
amount of videos generated every year
and it's not just the hundreds of
millions of cameras all around us it's
the billions of cellphones we all keep
our pocket prism is a cloud software
company that connects to cameras that
already exist in the marketplace and
analyzes that video in a way no human
can it slices and dices the video and
puts that into our data structure so
it's searchable and available to
companies Microsoft is a big part of the
smarts that helped the indexing and
understanding and video happen to use
prism all you have to do is pull out
your phone and type in what is you're
looking for and where and prism will
find it
the value comes from unlocking the
hidden information and video and that
can be just as valuable for a factory or
construction site or hospital as it is
for retail stores tourism also takes
that video feed and turns it into a
stream of information that can be used
to let that business run better
Microsoft's computer vision API can
understand different kinds of objects
text other types information
merchandisers might use us to look into
their stores around the world or people
in retail operations might use us to
build a dashboard of important metrics
places like hospitals or health care
facilities can use prism to understand
where their doctors are so they can more
quickly connect those doctors with
patients in verticals like industrial or
construction prism can be used to help
track really important critical
machinery if you're on a construction
site and you wanted to be notified when
this the Met mixer arrived you can use
AI to do that prism brings a really
unique set of content into the world of
AI and machine learning in Microsoft
brings one of the best technology and
people in the world to help understand
that crime it's an exciting time and the
coolest thing about it is we're just
getting started
great so now let's show you a demo of
activating AI development of DNS and the
scenario we're going to show is one we
call snow leopards and scaling BNN it's
on a data set of Snow Leopard images so
to do that demo let me invite Ted way my
colleague in crime Ted all right all
right Thank You Joseph so I'd like you
to take a look at this image and tell me
what you see probably take you a second
or two but you'll notice the Snow
Leopard at the bottom right and this is
motivation with the work that we're
doing with a Snow Leopard trust finding
snow leopards has been pretty difficult
there's only about 6500 of them left in
the wild and the Snow Leopard Trust is
committed to to protecting them and
so they know that snow leopards roam in
an area of about 1.5 million square
kilometers they set up camera traps
about 42 traps over the years they've
collected about 1.3 million images even
then it's only covering about 0.1% of
where snow leopards roam but you kind of
get an idea of the problem that they're
facing as a non-profit when they need to
do a survey they're collecting all these
images takes 300 hours just to do a
manual survey because every time there's
motion that camera is triggered whether
it's going to be livestock whether it
could be a blade of grass swaying in the
wind all these things would result in
these images and so this is where really
just like the video we saw the ability
to be able to apply AI to help
nonprofits other businesses like Snow
Leopard trust to be able to enable them
to automatically classify these images
so what we're using is something called
transfer learning so it's joseph mention
you have these amazing deep neural nets
today that can extract really cool
features from images so something like
resident 50 which is a deep neural net
is pretty good on various animals to
give it a picture of an elephant runs it
through the deep neural net extract the
features and it classifies as an element
so how do we take make use of all of
that goodness in a deep neural net and
apply it to your specific application so
what we're doing is transfer learning
where we're taking images of snow
leopards and then just chopping off one
or more layers at the end and so we use
the deep neural net as a feature riser
it's still looking at the images
extracting the features and then those
features become an input to a classifier
such as the logistic regression
classifier from spark ml and now we can
train it to be able to do binary
classification to determine whether
there's a snow leopard in the image or
not and we're using a library called FML
spark you can go to github today and
I'll show you a link in a little bit but
you can download this to really be able
to help you accelerate your development
of AI applications if you were to use
something like plain PI spark and in
this case we're trying to look at the
adult income the adult census income
data set basically you have to import
this and there's a lot of things that
you have to do every learner is very
specific so keeping track of feature
column names manually encoding the
categoricals doing manual vector
Emily because the learner expects that
every learner is different every learner
has different conventions there's a lot
of ceremonial code that you have to
write just to be able to do these tasks
and now you have to convert the label to
a format expected by the learner so a
lot of this code using FML spark can be
condensed into just a few lines and so
this is a library that we're making
available it's open source on github to
be able to help you develop a lot more
quickly and so without deep future
ization if we were to just use something
like open CV we could get about 68%
accuracy on snow level classification
but using deep feature a feature ization
we can get up to eighty nine percent
accuracy and so just to show you the
code right here we have we have our FML
spark library and I'm not going to run
this I already ran this because it's
going to take a few minutes to run but
basically what we're able to do now is
importing the cognitive toolkit models
so these models are available to you so
that you can also use them reading the
images here and now we're going to load
the metadata and then constructing the
model you can see here where I'm using
things like the image transformer or the
image feature Iser from the MLL spark
library to be able to make things a lot
easier and now I'm building my logistic
regression classifier taking the
features from that deep neuron that
running a few mileage istic regression
classifier and then evaluating the model
so I'm training it and then I'm testing
it so now I have the ability to be able
to build a spark pipeline and with that
spark pipelines there are a lot of
things I can do with it I think I can
package that up into a docker container
and then be able to inference based on
that so now running my Snow Leopard
images through the doctor container now
I can determine whether there's no
leopard in the image or not and so so
I'd encourage all of you to jump here to
to check out MML part
putting feet up 22c okay
okay to be able to check out FML spark
on github you can just run this run this
command to is just run the docker
container and it's just a really cool
way to easily get started and it's
Joseph mentioned because of these deep
neural nets they're getting really
really complex and really hard to serve
on CPUs
okay great so if we look at the types of
hardware the silicon alternatives are
available to us to be able to serve deep
neural nets on the scale of flexibility
and efficiency we have our CPUs at the
left CPUs you know are very general but
the price you pay for being very general
is performance and CPUs are just
processing things sequentially there
general but slow for GPUs they're
basically able to process things in
parallel so you get things a lot faster
for all you gamers out there you
probably also know GPUs are expensive so
it's not that easy to be able to just
buy a lot of GPUs and run them at your
far end of the scale and efficiency you
have a six which are application
specific integrated circuits so these
are chips basically that have the
circuitry burn on to them if you open up
your say your air conditioner your
dishwasher those little black chips
that's basically an ASIC the nice thing
about them is they're very efficient
very low-power the problem is that once
you create that circuit it's set if you
had to create anything new you would
literally have to recreate that circuit
go to the factory order more and then
install them FPGAs are field
programmable gate arrays makes it in a
nice sweet spot between flexibility and
efficiency and so you have the ability
to be able to flash that ship with a
model such as a deep neural net and then
once that chip is in there whether it's
going to be a factory robot whether it's
going to be a drone whether it's going
to be a driverless car you have the
ability to be able to update that model
and update that chip without having to
change any hardware so the nice thing
about FPGAs is one just from a
performance perspective you can see that
you can get tens to hundreds of Terror
ops you can get performance ten times or
even more than CPUs and GPUs and in
terms of flexibility because DNS and
Sheen learning a is rapidly evolving as
things change you have the ability to be
able to flash different models onto that
ship without having to change the
hardware Microsoft has the world's
largest cloud investment in FPGAs today
if you were to use Azure as your uses
FPGAs for software-defined networking
and being you also use FPGAs today for
query serving and talking about being
these are actual production results from
December 2015 where they took one of
their models ran it on software CPUs and
you can see that on top
where it's running slower latencies
higher FPGAs latency slower and you can
serve more queries per second you can
also see that the average FPGA query
load on the lower right is actually
higher than CPUs because you have so
many more queries that are able to be
run on that FPGA so I'm going to do I'm
going to show a quick quick demo of
FPGAs
so being used as a model which very
simplistically what being does is every
time you serve every time you give it a
query it takes that query string takes a
document runs it through a big complex
model and gives you a relevant score
take the same query string runs it
through a different document gives you a
relevant score very very simplistically
then it sorts all the results and gives
you the top-ranked documents any search
engine does this so we were to take this
model run it on one CPU you can see that
I can run about two or three documents
per second and so that just gives you an
idea of just how expensive these deep
neural nets are I can only run takes me
half a second to run this model and in a
typical scenario what I would do is
throw more CPUs at the problem so I have
a being server these servers are many
many thousands of dollars twenty four
CPUs drawing about three hundred watts
of power and I can get to about 80
documents per second just less
contention on the CPU so now on the CPUs
and I'm able to get more throughput
which is good but let's see what happens
if we take that same model and run it on
24 FPGAs instead so now I have that
model burn on to 24 FPGAs you can see
here that it's getting about 15,000
17,000 documents per second so really
the ability to be able to accelerate AI
to enable you to have the use of the
fastest AI cloud on the planet from a
software perspective in terms of the
libraries to be able to accelerate
development and also hardware
perspective to be able to accelerate
running all of these models is really
what we wanted to so thank you very much
thank you dick
so you saw a lot of things there and let
me just recap what we what we show you
know first of all we showed taking a
data set are really hard to detect it's
a hard data set of images is really hard
to detect things like identifying a snow
leopard in the wild they're only a small
number of images of these even I mean
they do have you know a few 10 mm mm
maybe low hundreds of thousands but what
you know you're able to do though is to
take a deep neural network that had been
trained on millions of images take that
and draw up a draw that as a feature
Iser and then use that as the basis on
top of which to learn to classify snow
leopard images right so you did that and
to do that at scale you needed a
platform like spark so spark was the
platform in which you hosted the data
the big data and then you run all of
this feature isolation in a distributed
way you learnt the model to detect
smaller parts and then you deploy that
and so when you deploy these models you
need speed and so traditional CPUs are
slow and so you need custom hardware
like FPGA is to make these executable
and low latency is like 15 millisecond
latency incredible throughput and low
cost as well FPGA czar potentially a
hundred to thousand times cheaper than
just using a CPU and so then we showed
that ability as well and so you have
stitched all of these capabilities
together the ability to take a pre plain
feature icer learn on spark with the
custom data set deploy it into hardware
and create a web service in the cloud
that can in the future they used to
detect snow leopards right and so type
of pipeline that a lot of custom machine
learning applications will go through
and Python and pipe spark is a very
integral part of that pipeline to make
that flow happen so you can build and
deploy a custom machine learning AI
application in the car okay great so now
how about making all of this
easier to get started one of the areas
where we have invested a fair amount is
in the IDS and tooling around machine
learning period and not just machine
learning but it's a much more general
purpose so you can do any data signs
with it so many of you know about Python
tools for visual studio which has been
very popular for quite a long time it is
about 60,000 monthly active users we
launched our tools for visual studio in
GA a few months back its users went from
approximately 4,000 per month last
summer to around 7,000 in May and then
we are hosted free Asher notebooks
Jupiter notebooks are nasha it's super
popular super popular with universities
there are about two hundred eight
thousand notebooks now hosted on the
cloud and this is free we hosted
lightweight docker containers and so we
are able to offer a free service there
and then we've got a plug-in now for
vyas code there's a BS code - community
extension that is actually 2.8 million
downloads and is ranked the number one
extension downloaded for BS code and we
just hide Don who's being the author of
it into shadow extreme here that runs
Python so we have an exciting investment
collection of investment in Python and
our in Microsoft so we do yet another
thing to make these things easier now in
the earlier demo I talked about a full
pipeline it turns out when you really
build an application and production in
enterprise you're composing many many
different services together your
services to bring data into the cloud
you have services in which you wrangle
the data transform the data then you
have to plug in identity you have to
plug in any multiple collections of
components so how do you make it easy to
build these kinds of solutions and how
do you provide a kit so to speak that
makes it easy to plug these things in
and
a 10-2 and applications that's what we
address with Cortana intelligence
solution templates so you can go to our
website called gallery Cortana
intelligence gallery if you search it in
any search engine you'll find
Continentals gallery and there you will
find a reference architectures for
common scenarios and it's built on you
know best practices of designing such as
a lambda architecture for both streaming
analytics and batch analytics then it
can automatically deploy to the cloud
subscription and it's customizable so
here are examples that you will see on
the Cortana intelligence gallery you
will see say if you want to build an
long credit with sequel server or
personalized recommendations in the
cloud how do you build a personalized
recommendations application the cloud by
composing together many services
including machine learning and so it's
possible to create an architecture a
reference architecture like this they
can actually with a few clicks be
instantiated in the cloud so you're
bringing all these services up
provisioning them connecting them up
setting up data flows and you are able
to create a full architecture for
creating personalized recommendations so
that's what the Cortana intelligence
solution templates do and then the third
thing that we do is provide tooling like
data signs virtual machines so for
people who are really expert data
science users having a very good virtual
machine installed with all the
components that they need to do data
science effectively it's actually very
very useful so in otherwise you have to
get a virtual machine then download and
install every piece of software and
there's a lot of complexity involved in
just even setting up your data center
environment so the data science virtual
machine makes it easy it includes all
the key popular tools whether it be our
Python and Julia or deep neural network
tools like tensorflow and c and TK and
others machine learning libraries like
even h2o or MX net so we bring all of
these pre-installed in a data center
virtualization of development
environments Cortana intelligence
solution templates
data
Virtual Machines now the third part of
the story is about bringing AI to the
data platforms now there are really
powerful data services available today
on Azure whether it be a database like
sequel server or a big data service like
HD insight that runs spark or big even
bigger data service called actual data
Lake that allows you to run jobs jobs
for data cooking all of these are very
powerful platforms offered as fully
managed services on the cloud so then
the question is can you make it possible
to run AI inside those data platforms
right next to the data without moving
the data out that's very powerful so let
me tell you a little bit more about the
this is sort of the concept of bringing
computation and algorithms in this
particular case intelligence to where
the data lives and where the data is
produced as opposed to moving data to
where you want to do the algorithmic
computer and actually a very important
principle in accelerating and deploying
AI and why is that important so bear
with me a minute I want you to think
about the time before databases were
invented well before databases were
invented when people build data-driven
applications the application has to do a
lot of heavy lifting you have to figure
out how to organize the data there to
figure out how to schema ties it had to
figure out how to index the data and it
had to be all secure highly available
backed up reliable and also ah
now when database management systems
were invented
we separated that function and
abstracted it out and removed it from
the application tier so database
management systems that became really
great storing data indexing it
schematized and creating schemas
allowing joins query processing query
optimization access control security
backup failover reliability everything
that is required to build an
industrial-strength application okay
that made the application development
tomorrow
simpler so people invariably just put
their data in a database and application
tier just connects from that database
and forgets about all of this heavy
overhead associated with data
unfortunately the way most AI
applications are built today is like the
time before databases were invented okay
so what people do is that the
application tier for AI or machine
learning theory really it connects to
lots of databases it pulls in the data
it joins them it computes variables it
builds machine learning models in there
it deploys it in that same application
tier and then when you have to build a
highly available reliable secure
compliant application that applies that
up here that doesn't go down the
application tier that the application
tier is become incredibly hard to build
and maintain and it just really is
incredible overhead so why would you
want to replicate all this heavy lifting
that databases solve for you already
wouldn't you wouldn't you be much better
off actually moving the AI into where
the database is and just letting the
algorithm run inside the database and
inherit all the benefits of that
database the compliance boundary the
security and all of that and that's the
that's the key direction
so with sequel server 2017 which we
which is in community technology preview
now 2.0 and it's going into production a
big way we brought this principle to
life so this is a really by the way the
first commercial database with AI built
in yeah it has AI store procedures in R
and Python so any R and Python code that
you actually write can now run inside
sequel server in the secure compliant
boundary and indeed your query can now
include our scripts or Python scripts
and by the way a sequel server provides
for concurrency and throughput and all
that it's managed it allows
failover it has replication it's back up
all sorts of features accommodate with
all that is inherited by the application
now and then in that same sequence over
you now also have support for analyzing
complex relationship graph data so when
you want to do machine learning on
interrelationships and graph
now that's possible as well and it
incorporates machine learning even for
speeding up query processing it's got an
unparalleled performance with adaptive
query processing so when you bring all
of that to life what you can do is to
leverage all the benefits of an
industrial-strength database to build a
very powerful air application extremely
simply most of the complexity is living
in the database server and AI
application can be a very thin layer
that connects to a database and issues
code and code intelligent queries or AI
queries the best way to see this is
really with the demo so now let me
invite submit Kumar to show a demo of
sequel server wit Python actually
building a sophisticated AI app take it
away Thank You Joseph good morning
everyone I'm very excited to show you
the deep integration of Python in sequel
server and I'm going to show you how to
build and deploy a Python application
completely inside a sequencer and not
just any application a GPU powered deep
learning application that does a
classification of medical imaging data
all right let's switch to this demo
machine so what you're seeing here is an
app a patient portal lab that you could
find in a radiologists office so I come
in and I want to see the report of a new
patient I load up the report for that
patient and so far everything is just
normal looking a patient portal app but
when I hit this analyze button there is
a deep learning model in running in the
background that goes and analyzes
hundreds of images that make up this
person's CT scan and comes back with a
suggested probability that this person
has a chance of having lung cancer now
this augments my judgment as a doctor
and increases the accuracy and speed of
detection right that has used advantages
for both healthcare cost savings as well
as for patient outcomes so typically
these applications are very hard to do
so in the learning phase we take took
all the images and then we generated
features from it we used transfer
learning using a pre-built DNN model
that comes with the cognitive toolkit
that we are using in this application
and from the features and the labels you
train a classifier model and in the
application you're using that mod to
score the new data that comes in right
so there are quite a few challenges in
this in this process first of all be as
joseph was saying the intelligence has
to be built in the application that
means the data scientists and the
application developers have to work
hand-in-hand oftentimes they're
indifferent or they're using different
set of tools so that presents a lot of
challenges and then the data needs to be
moved to the application and oftentimes
moving you know petabytes gigabytes
terabytes of data around is not easy you
have to build massive amounts of data
movement infrastructure for that so
often you're forced to work with samples
and in deep learning domain if you're
working with smaller samples of data
your model quality is impacted and that
is if you're allowed to move data and
medical domain like this you just simply
not allowed to moved it out of the
compliance and secure boundaries like
sequel server so in in this app though I
didn't have to do any of that the all
the data model features everything is
sitting in sequel server in a secure way
in different tables and all the compute
all the AI logic is written in Python
code which are embedded in sequel
scripts and the application on the
right-hand is just making a call to a
store simple simple one-line call to a
stored procedure and getting all the
intelligence it selects which to
machine again and so here's the actual
app code I'm using vs code and rest of
the code is just plumbing and layout etc
there's just one line that is serving
all the intelligence which is just
making a call to that stored procedure
so the real magic is all happening
inside of sequence over here in sequence
over the the image these are the actual
images stored as numpy arrays and in a
table called scan images and there are
these stored procedures that are doing
all the generate feature generation
doing actual model training and doing
the actual predictions so let's take a
look at one of these stored procedures
this is where we do the feature
generation this looks like any other
regular T sequel script but it has this
special system stored procedure called
SP execute external script which knows
how to take Python or our script and
executed from sequel and it takes one of
the parameters is the script actual
script so here is where the actual
Python code is so I'll not show you the
whole thing but just some relevant lines
of code here
okay so here I am loading the cognitive
toolkit model the ResNet 1:52 model that
comes with a skog native toolkit I
didn't have to train that complex TNN
model as Joseph described that takes a
lot of expertise time and resources so I
was able to leverage it as is and I'm in
this loop I am cycling through all the
images for the entire corpus of data and
I'm doing some additional manipulations
again using open source libraries like
open CV and then I'm generating features
here and I'm inserting that those
generated features back into a sequel
server table so the data never leaves
sequel server so one of the things again
even with the pre trained DNN model the
actual features generation is a very
computer intensive process so this
machine has a number of GPOs I was able
to leverage that GPU using the cognitive
toolkit again and because of that the
entire feature a feature ization of more
than a quarter million images was done
in less than an R on a this is actually
a regular data science VM that Joseph
was talking about without GPU it takes
more than 30 hours so it's about 30x
advantage so then once the features are
written I again use these different
stored procedure to train the classifier
model and in this final scoring sorry
anyway so and the scoring a stored
position again I'm making using that
model and taking the new patience
features and generating scores and the
application was again just making a
one-line stored procedure call so that's
the power of sequel server the
commercial database for AI and machine
learning thank you thank you very much
of it right so submit showed a very
simple application development scenario
with a I using sequel server and you
know you can actually now download it at
this website in fact if you search it
you will find sequel 2017 a full
developer edition downloadable with
which you can actually do AI and have AI
run inside the database so now let's
talk about bringing AI to every
developer and most developers are really
not in the business of building AI from
scratch
and would really love to have AI
functions available to you in my dream
would be in many ways a lot of AI it
just becomes like a sort function in a
programming language now we can't quite
achieve that but we can simplify a lot
of AI functions and offer them as REST
API is in the club so that's what a sure
is doing with API it's called cognitive
service API and we have a very very rich
collection of those things and so let me
actually go to the cognitive services
collection so they are a number of API
is for understanding content of images
for recognizing faces for creating chat
applications for even training deep
neural networks and so here is a list of
things that's available you have API
submission you have a ps4 language you
have API for speech for search and for
knowledge so on vision there will be a
computer vision face recognition a
motion detection content moderation
filtering out objectionable content
those kinds of things on language
text analytics it spellcheck its web
language model linguistic analysis and
so on in speech will be speaker
recognition and actual speech
recognition and then search a lot of
them and so on
imagine the power of these available to
you as a simple API call into Azure that
you can just integrate into your
applications and make the applications
be actually really smart without a lot
of work now this is the power of the
cloud by the way behind AI now vast
majority of functions will eventually
become just api's I mean you're already
familiar with Bing Maps and Google Maps
is simple API you can integrate
applications very soon you will have
tens of thousands perhaps even in
somewhere in the future million AI apps
are hosted on the cloud which you can
get seamlessly integrating your
applications really very powerful so
then you will end up actually having
having applications that can actually
see here listen and understand respond
to people and it can even be done on
custom data or data that you actually
are care about like snow leopards not
just anything on wild on the internet
but just things that you really care
about so you have custom vision service
custom language understanding to
understand specific speech components
and commands you give our speed service
and custom search and so on so we are on
a very rapid innovation track to launch
lots of api's that democratize AI again
the power of this is best seen through a
demo so let me in my Carlos pessoa who's
a developer in my team who's build some
amazing applications just by wrapping
this API he's able to do that in a
matter of days and will extremely
powerful air applications so Carlos
still let me just switch here
it's not going there if I connect the
cable that'll help all right there you
go
so what Joseph just showed you like the
cognitive services that they are very
very powerful for developers basically
like years and years of research and all
these a is right there all these ideas
are Web API s so for any platform any
any language really if you can make HTTP
requests you can tap into all that power
and suddently like your app can
understand all these these things that
typically humans claim so for the
question I have I have been working on
an effort to try to showcase some of
this API still some end-to-end stories
and one of the ways that that word
materialized was through this
application called intelligent kiosk
it's a universal web for Windows but
like I said it would work in any
platform and in this particular one here
what I'm doing is just augmenting a
camera in this case this is a regular
RGB camera this is a regular laptop and
it's there you can see it's predicting
my age my gender emotions so if I smile
they're so happy and on the only bottom
right you see the latency that this is
taking and within that time it's doing
all this computation and it's even
trying to identify my face in this case
it's not doing it because I haven't done
that yet but I saved that so you can get
life together so you see how fast this
is so associate with the face API you
can you can create labelled faces by
name and then you can provide samples
for those names and in this case my app
here happens to integrated Bing images
so you can it by that name it tries to
find images the first one happens to be
me so that helps when I click this
button look how fast this takes
boom so that now that
network that the DNN behind out this
that we know this face analysis it now
knows that face and it's comparing
that's that same spin and this could be
like thousands of faces it's not just
one it's really cool how it be scales
out another another service that we we
recently launched is the ability to
create our own image classifier and
basically what there is is what you just
talked about a lot earlier today
having a DNN wrapped up in the cloud
that you can basically go in tailor to
your needs and I have done that already
with a few different models I have one
for traffic conditions and for weather
conditions and video categories so for
example if I take and wanna target a
picture against this one if I take for
example this one here like a school bus
it gets scored as a school bus and well
I had to do as a developer all these
obviously applies I have been for you to
train any score against I just had to
like label pictures on that so if I go
here and look for the school bus you see
the pictures that I label not not a lot
but what I want to do here is to create
a new one so I have two objects here I
have a Pepsi and a coke bottle and we
tried it together very quickly here
create a model to identify them so I'm
going to start by great labeling the
name of that projects alcoholic drinks
are you call why you at the first tag
like that's the cocktail and again like
this is going to be images trying to
find images so I'm going to just take
five pictures this is the minimum that
we require and sometimes you need more
we're going to see how it's going to do
we just file as you can imagine the
pictures that I'm not loading here they
are slightly different than the one I'm
going to score with my webcam the angle
might be different let me take one more
this one here somebody holding there you
go let's do one for the Pepsi
let me put Pepsi Candice I get more the
King focus there you go
and again like I'm going to click that
train button and then you're going to
see this is going to be about a few
seconds worth of time and I didn't have
to deploy anything create any machines
this is all in the cloud I have a REST
API endpoint that I can call any score
against so when I go back here now I
have my my model and they're going to
see if it's going to work or not or if
we might need to automate with some more
images but let me bring up the camera
here and just point and see how that's
going to work
oh that's not bad it was a hundred
percent coffee - it's a Pepsi and about
18 as a coke and probably because of the
shape of the cane like there is a lot of
similar features the thing that you so
let us try with the coke the coke bottle
and do the same thing a hundred percent
so there you go we just did it together
here just a few seconds and it's all
available to you today to have either
subscription you can get these keys and
go into the same the same type of thing
and we hone is going to show one more
scenario around this as well exactly
so one of the things that Carlos has
showed right is just in a short period
of time we can create really powerful
applications but this is PyCon right and
one of the things that is back off of my
right now is that if you look through
all the cognitive services right that's
human cognitive services that you can
use today right from vision to being
able to detect our gender and so on and
so forth right or even being able to
detect landmarks right and on top of
this you have also other kinds of
services right one of them being which
is also part of cognitive services it's
translated so this is right and you say
no I have now a rich set of collection
of AI functions as Joseph's closet if I
have a Python application how can I
invoke it without training the model
without worrying about the
infrastructure and so and so forth right
so one of the things that you see here
is we've pre created a cognitive service
in this case is a Translate API which
would take any arbitrary text in any
language and translate it to a target
language of your choice right and what
I'm going to show you next really
quickly is how then you can invoke this
in your code in your Python code right
so right now what you see here is a
really simple notebook right and of
course we're just putting in the
subscription key which is returned to
you by cognitive services right and let
me just run this and then of course you
specify a bunch of rest api URLs that
you can even book right in this case
these are all given to you in the
posture so I'm just gonna specify them
once you have that and you have the
subscription key then you go on to get
the access token right and at this point
I'm already I'm already to do
translation right right there in your
Python app right and this just walks you
through what does translation how does
the translation API works and so on and
so forth right I'm not going to go
through this and you can find it online
but let's see translation action right
right now what I have here is a text
which is in French
I think French is a beautiful language
I'm still trying to pick it up right and
I'm going to say my target language is
English because most of us the English
in this audience and click on this and
observe what happened right I have
specified the soft language the target
language
and right now I'm just going to invoke
the AI function in the cloud which is
cognitive service and I'm already to
show you the response right and
therefore you have your original text
right there in your Python code it
invoked an AI function and it returns
you a beautiful French text that's all
we have fun for you today thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much be hung so the three
revolutions brewing in computing today
the revolution of the cloud the
revolution of data and the revolution of
intelligence every software application
of the future is really going to be at
the corner of the cube defined by these
three axis on the cloud all in the data
and applying AI to that data to drive
intelligent customer experiences and
intelligent business plastics so today
in the review I already covered a whole
collection of this you know inferencing
that fpg is to make things how fast in
the cloud the cloud because of its
economies of scale can deploy custom
hardware for AI that is accessible now
to every developer in the world that
itself is a big step change that's what
specific hardware like FPGA is elevated
there are solution templates we can
provide to compose many very
sophisticated services available for
data and AI to build entire applications
in the cloud there are things like
distance virtual machines and databases
like sequel server available in the
cloud or on premises with AI embedded in
it we talked about deep learning it's
part we talked about cognitive services
custom vision and a number of demos that
you just saw from Carlos pasilla
Illustrated a number of these scenarios
and then we talked about also
capabilities like ashram machine
learning so this is just really the tip
of the iceberg in the coming AI
Ellucian so think about this in about
1769 James Ward invented the steam
engine the invention of the steam engine
had altered the Industrial Revolution
there are few decades after the
invention of the steam engine was
entirely transforming for for the planet
we are today at a similar juncture the
intelligent cloud is the steam engine of
the 21st century and the decades before
us is really the time of the
intelligence evolution thank you very
much
[Applause]